hey youtubers it's Charlie since we've
all had time to process the Walking Dead
midseason finale I thought it was time
to start talking about what's going to
be happening in 2014 and the rest of the
season
aside from everyone dying horribly Game
of Thrones style so this video will be
my top 10 predictions for the second
half of season 4
since we've got about 8 weeks before
Walking Dead comes back I'll also be
doing bonus videos every single week be
sure to subscribe to get all those
videos and let me know in the comments
if there's anything special you want me
to include in those so in the name of
sweet baby Judith let's get started
number 10 direct comic book adaptations
so Robert Kirkman said that the follow
up to the prison attack in episode 8
will be a direct adaptation or a more
faithful adaptation to what happens in
the comic books so I don't want to spoil
it too much for anyone that hasn't read
but the story will pick up directly
after the events of this last episode
number 9 the fate of baby Judith so I
saw an overwhelming number of comments
about people thinking that she was dead
if you take a closer look at that
stroller there's a lot of evidence that
points to her still being alive of all
the theories the most likely are one
Tyreese grabbed her in Lizzie's group
and they ran into the woods or two she
made it to the bus with another person
let me know below in the comments though
do you feel like if she would have
actually been confirmed dead you would
have rage quit the show or it kept on
watching number eight Sheriff Carl so
what I mean when I say Sheriff Carl is
just that Carl's taking more of a
leadership position mostly out of
necessity if you saw Rick during that
last episode he basically just slowly
died inside until he almost became
catatonic obviously he was able to run
away with Carl into the woods but it
seems like based on the teaser for
episode 9 Rick is still emotionally and
physically recovering from the beating
that the governor gave him so Carl
basically has to take care of them
number 7 new characters so this includes
Abraham Eugene and Rosita so they're
from the comic books and we haven't met
them yet and when it probably won't show
up till episode 10 but because in the
comic books the prison group met
Abraham's group on Hershel's farm and on
the show in season 2 Herschel Swampert
they might end up changing a little bit
how they introduce them into the story
the cool thing we do know about
Abraham's group though is that they will
get their full own episode that kind of
explains where they've been up to this
point just like the governor got his own
episode before episode 8 number 6 new
splinter groups obviously both the
prison and the governor's group were
decimated and now they've kind of split
off as they run off into the
away from the walkers this kind of leads
to some new interesting pairings so we
have a couple possible groups that the
governor's people could join one there's
Tyreese and Lizzie that ran off into the
woods with baby Judith hopefully there's
two there's Rick's group and then three
there's the group on the bus so you will
see a lot of interesting mashups just
like last season when the woods Berry
group joined the prison group don't you
just think it would be a little bit
poetic if Lily and Tara ended up joining
Rick's group number five the return of
Morgan so Morgan has almost been gone
for a full two seasons and he kind of
left Rick in a really bad place
obviously they almost kind of tried to
kill each other I feel like that's the
way a lot of people leave each other on
Walking Dead
but he is coming back and it's possible
that rip troop could run into him on the
way to Washington DC but since they're
changing a little bit about the way we
meet Abraham's group the same could
happen for Morgan rejoining Rick's group
number for the return of Carol so a lot
of you guys commented that Carol would
probably be back before the end of
season 4 and TV Guide is actually
reporting that she will be back she
won't be back right away but she will be
rejoining Daryl's pretty remember
they're the ones that heard the beacon
from the sanctuary number three a brand
new character named Gareth that's gonna
be an amalgam of a couple of the comic
book characters but he will be a little
bit of an unknown at first Hollywood
Reporter is saying that he's actually
very important to the story in the
second half of season 4 we don't know he
could either be one of two things he
could have something to do with the
Alexandria safe zone or two he could be
the Chris character the leader of the
hunters number two the hunters are
coming it's unconfirmed whether or not
season four will only mention the
hunters or if we'll actually meet them
Rick's group actually encounters them on
the way to Washington DC in the comic
books so it's possible that we could see
that towards the end of this season but
it's actually a fairly significant event
so it might not be till much much later
and my number one thing to look forward
to when Walking Dead comes back the
Alexandria safe zone and the sanctuary
if you remember Dale's group before they
had to abandon the charger actually
heard a mysterious message from
someplace calling themselves to the
sanctuary it's my belief that that is
actually the Alexandria safe zone but we
don't know if that's going to tie into
Gareth's character the hunters or
possibly another group of villains that
we haven't met yet I don't want to tease
those group of villains because that's
so far off that it might not happen till
season 5 but if you've read the comic
books then you probably know what I'm
talking about
but let me know below in the comments
what are you most excited to see in the
second half of season 4 and do you think
we'll meet the hunters like I said I'll
be doing bonus Walking Dead videos every
week for the next eight weeks
so Walking Dead comes back be sure to
let me know what you want me to include
in those videos right now click here to
get my midseason finale WTF video and
click here to get all my other videos
from season four so far thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives